of investigative reporters on the line
here James O'Keefe who launched a brand
new organization uh today called OMG
hey guys this is James O'Keefe how you
doing Tim can you turn the volume up
somewhere hell yeah dude this is as high
as I can get it James make sure you're
not on like airpods or anything is it is
that okay and on speaker okay there we
go hey guys can you hear me yes
hey Tim Tim it's James I'm doing I'm
doing pretty well
well I just launched a new thing so
Keith Media Group I just wanted to call
in to tell you guys hello I appreciate
you guys being there for me absolutely
watching all your episodes and you were
pretty much right on about it also thank
you Tim for being a good stand-up guy
well uh we all we all appreciate the the
work you do one of the last few if not
the last real news organization and and
newsman and uh what happened with
project Veritas was shocking so we're
excited to see O'Keefe Media Group we
got we got the Tweet pulled up you want
to pull up that while James is talking
we actually have your video we're gonna
play in a second so James how nice
what's the premise hey the premise is
like uber for journalism we're going to
be sending thousands of cameras to
people all over the world and we've
already have a few hundred
um that have emailed us today and they
want to wear the camera so we're gonna
our website's gonna be totally dedicated
to equipping mobilizing empowering and
training citizen journalists on the
scale of likes you've never seen before
in your life and so many people after
what happens when you empathize your
story we're inspired
um so we're just gonna make do this on a
massive scale now
um and uh you have the website it's it's
live I Benny I was inspired by Benny's
uh film Noir the his his style and we
had me getting out of a black car okay
caught that joke Tim he also had me
stealing someone's sandwich yep
I don't know if you guys get that's an
inside joke you you have to read between
the lines and then some little dancing
because people don't like when I dance
it really upsets demons when I dance I
don't like that at all like that's
really angry about me being artistic so
a lot in there uh OMG O'Keefe Media
Group
um and thank you guys for just just
being good people for being real I hope
too awesome visit you down there yeah
come by anytime we're gonna play your
video and we're gonna talk about your
new adventure we'll talk about corporate
press and all that stuff in a moment
I want to come down there and talk to
you about corporate press and ownership
and I've just learned so much but uh
definitely piss off the haters share
that video of me dancing getting out of
black car stealing sandwiches sandwiches
always taste better
when they were in the hands of a
pregnant lady so well you imagine the
way it is
I say that tongue-in-cheek okay just for
all of you listeners I'm being I'm being
a little ironic there right on but
thanks thanks Tim no seriously man good
work appreciate it uh one question James
are you working what are you what are
you working on right now
oh gee I mean first of all we have a
follow-up on the fire story we got we
got a massive tip
um a lot of three-letter government
agency stuff coming in through our
Pipeline and um what aren't we working
on I'm in the little war room with 10
people these are ride or die people
these are really good people that are
been working 15 hours a day
over the last few days so you'll see our
next story in the coming days guys it's
gonna be big that's how you're going to
turn this around in days that's
unbelievable
that's how we roll it'll keep meeting
group OMG OMG I love the name the name
is so good well we gotta get you out
here sometime so as soon as you can
I have a I've learned a lot about uh as
you say ownership of media we're really
wanna that's a theme I want to touch on
with you so I have a few stories so
thanks thanks guys I gotta run Benny
you're the best thank you James thanks
James so uh let's let us show you the
video from O'Keefe media so you can
watch it for yourself and uh I'll just
play it decide here we go there we go
the irony of the acorn story is that it
took a 25 year old with a hidden camera
a few days to do what billion dollar
networks and journalists could not do in
a decade I spent 14 years creating the
most effective non-profit Newsroom this
country has ever seen and in Paving the
way to establish citizen journalism I
have been defamed arrested rated
ultimately removed from the organization
I spent so much time developing
credibility of I always knew they would
try to ruin the reputations of those who
exposed them the farmer Giants the
three-letter government agencies and
those who I thought I could trust but in
response we are going to build an army
of investigators and exposures they have
awakened sleeping giant I'm back
remaining by my side are a small
tight-knit group of the most elite
journalists in the world exposing
corruption requires standing up to power
because power hates sunlight we are
sunlight welcome to the O'Keefe Media
Group where we will never be shut down
because not only do I own it but you own
it to support us and sponsor our army of
journalists by becoming a founding
member today
OMG let me let me that was fast I mean
what was that a couple weeks ago let me
tell you how I knew James was going to
be successful in this I've known James
for nion a decade we both worked at
Breitbart way in the early days back
when Breitbart was still doing red eye
and all old school Breitbart right and I
didn't know about James and Andrew
Breitbart is like hey there's a guy who
wants to play a pimp he's a white kid
isn't that crazy like white pimp he's
gonna get him he's gonna get like a fake
you held up your phone when the when he
called and his name was saved in your
phone and you could see what you saved
him and your phone is if someone can
like it's been in my phone like that for
10 years because that's how I remember
the kid and so so Andrew Breitbart is
coming in coming in like looking like a
wild man at some DC party he's like this
kid he's white he's got it's gonna be
crazy he's got a prostitute too
and he's gonna collapse Acorn and the
entire Obama regime the people who got
Obama elected this this guy's gonna come
and blow him up and sure enough like
James did it and James and I were like
Fast Friends he edited the acorn video
on my on my apartment couch wow he
edited the acorn videos there uh his
pimp jacket was in my closet for quite a
while before he was James O'Keefe and
then every single little things that
he's done some of some of the craziest
stuff some of the like like hey I'm
gonna try and seduce someone from CNN on
my boat like like you remember that one
no the old ones yeah the one yeah like
that was that was one that's gone I
remember them sideways Jon Stewart
praised him for the acorn stuff John
Stewart was like we've been had yeah
well he said how come you couldn't get
journalists to do this why is it up to
this kid to go in and uncover the stuff
and then when James will keep even
shared this when Jon Stewart showed the
clips he didn't insult or lie about what
James O'Keefe uncovered he went this
looked really bad what is this South
Park did an episode about James O'Keefe
I mean that's that's how we didn't
understand like it had permeated so big
South Park did an entire James O'Keefe
episode you can look it up which one was
that as I I'm sure the crowd the the the
uh chat will be able to Source it but
James actually watched that together it
was wild and so here's Trey Parker Matt
Stone doing it James O'Keefe Acorn
there's an acorn South Park episode
anyway James just lets it rip dude if
you like think you're gonna hold this
guy back you're gonna hurt his feelings
or anything like he says he danced like
Michael Jackson because it makes people
mad it just lets it rip and there's no
one who lets it rip he's more like a
skateboarder at heart like he's far more
of like an X Games guy I think he just
wants to like stick The Landing I think
they may have done him a favor with all
of this stuff because they untethered
him now he has an opportunity with all
of his experience knowledge his his
followers his fan base the people who
believe in him now he can start
something new clean and done right and
shave off all the fat and the bloat that
was probably holding him back yeah I
think it's an optimistic way to look at
it look I think Veritas getting hit the
way it did sucks for sure because it was
powerful and they did good work but
without James what do they have left
it's got to be with James and I think
this is a real opportunity for him to do
something stronger better faster Etc I
think it's actually turned out to be it
was a very good opportunity and he sees
the opportunity because if he had been
released from the company or fired it
when they weren't in the spotlight it
would have nowhere near this impact of
OMG taking off into the stratosphere
like it did so I'm you know talk about
taking a lemon and making lemonade man
uh I am concerned James that like
someone's going to come offer you 100
million dollars for the company you're
they're going to start to get deals and
offers and bribes God knows the
direction because it's going to be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars pretty
quick I would imagine yeah but don't
sell the Silicon Valley Bank James well
I suppose the question is if you're not
alone is he launching it as a non-profit
or a for-profit it sounds like oh yeah
good question well because I said
um on the episode he did say he watched
them on you want to talk about ownership
but I said it should be a for-profit
that means you're not going to get
donors in the same way and that that
could be an issue with project Veritas
that the 501c3 because there's that and
there's action which is I believe a
501c4 the 51c3 it's easy to get someone
to give you money
and expect nothing in exchange because
it's tax deductible you go to a rich guy
to give me half a million dollars you
can write it off they say okay
if you're a for-profit you can't do that
you're like you're gonna give me money
because you believe in the in in the
organization yeah and so a for-profit
will lose all of the high-level donors
but it's safer for you as someone who is
trying to maintain ownership and vision
and the message and all that stuff no
one can take it from you you talked
about it in the release video that it's
going to be owned by him and the
community or in insinuated that you are
also going to be part owner I don't know
what that means exactly maybe selling
off some stock to early investors or
something maybe I think maybe he's just
saying you guys become a member thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time